Hey guys, Matt here for Science or Fiction.
Doesn’t seem like all of those cool things
we dreamed about happening in the future are
finally becoming a reality?
Like flying cars.
Going to Mars.
Or cloning!
Next thing you know they’re gonna say that
floating cities are no longer a dream.
It says that right now, doesn’t it.
Yea, I thought so.
Are floating cities the new future of civilization?
Will we be living in aquatic societies in
the coming decades?
Well if you’re living off the coast of French
Polynesia, maybe?
The government of the collection of islands
in the South Pacific has agreed to develop
an experimental floating city with a group
called the Seasteading Institute by 2020.
The island will include residences, hotels,
restaurants, all the stuff you’d see in
a normal city, just out in the ocean.
In addition, the Seasteading Institute wants the city to function as a hub for scientific research.
Sounds super-futuristic and cool, right?
But is this as close to reality as these headlines
make it seem?
Well let’s look at the floating aspect of the
city first.
Technically the idea is similar to, but
not exactly an artificial island, which have
been around for a long time.
I mean people were building them 1,500 years ago in Micronesia and we still make them to this day.
Artificial islands are built on landfill,
they don’t float or move, and their construction
and can be environmentally disruptive.
What the Seasteading institute is proposing is much more advanced.
Their website states that they’ve settled
on a sustainable, modular design with interlocking
platforms that will actually float on the
water, which does sound pretty awesome.
And sure, floating villages are a thing that
already exist, too, but there isn’t a huge
city of this kind of scale floating around
right now.
Which also means, there’s also no promise
that it will work.
This is just a proposed design, we’ve never
done it before.
It’s kind of like the hyperloop.
It sounds super exciting, but what we’re
really talking about is a train, magnets and
pneumatic tubes, three old technologies that
may or may not work when we put them together.
And even if it DOES work, it might not ever
be put to use.
Sorry Elon.
So, for the moment, the floating city idea
may still be just science fiction.
But what about the scientific research hub
part, that sounds great, right?
Well due to the nature of living at sea, the project has begun focusing on studying sustainable
technologies like desalination, renewable
sources of energy, and how to grow food when
you’re stuck in the middle of the ocean.
Basically the island would be one big lab
for all of that.
And there are scientists who are really excited
about this kind of an opportunity.
But there are some skeptics of the project’s true intent, and that’s because the Seasteading Institute
was originally more about creating an independent nation than studying sustainable science.
The idea came from venture capitalists from Silicon Valley while at Burning Man.
And only good ideas come from Burning Man, right?
While the focus seems to have shifted towards
science, there’s still a political aspect
to this project.
Blue Frontiers, which is part of the Seasteading
Institute, wants a 0% tax rate from French
Polynesia on the island as well as regulatory
exceptions.
And in an interview with ABC News Australia,
Seasteading spokesman Joe Quirk talked about
floating islands creating new governments
and societies as if they were tech-startups.
And while French Polynesia does have a real
concern for rising sea levels for which a
floating city sounds like a solution, they’re
also mostly focused on economics.
The country has an 18% unemployment rate and
could really use the industry.
But whether the island is truly a haven for
science or just a playground for rich idealists,
the project is moving forward with its $60
million dollar price tag.
Funding will partially come from virtual currency
because, well, Burning Man, guys.
Of course it’s going to be funded with virtual currency.
But what do you think?
Are floating cities the wave of the future?
Or are they just something a bunch of rich
guys thought would be cool while dancing around
in the desert?
Personally, I won’t be working on my
sea legs anytime soon.
So jeez Matt, there are no floating cities
yet we get it, but what about stretchy batteries?
Ok, that’s a weird request.
But you know what here’s a video just about
that.
Because I care.
Don’t forget to subscribe, and make sure
to keep coming back to Seeker for more videos.